for thousands of students across the
valleys just to teach it also feeds
right it's so important Three Square
Food Bank as usual will provide summer
meals for CCSD students who are in need
Lauren negretti joining us live from El
Dorado High School to break down where
they can find those meals Lauren good
morning
good morning guys well that first
Morning Bell just went out here students
are here now ready for their last day of
school and on that topic of helping out
three square has their Meetup and eat-up
program supporting families by providing
free healthy meals for kids and teens 18
and younger now the program starts
Tuesday May 20 Tuesday May 23rd tomorrow
and goes through early August they're
set to give out 20 000 meals weekly all
summer you can find them at parks
recreation centers Boys and Girls Clubs
libraries and day camps plus some
apartment complexes using refrigerated
Vans to reach kids near home
there will be 20 rotating meals some
sites will have breakfast lunch or both
for that full list of where they're
going to be you can go to
freesummerfood.org live outside El
Dorado for the last day of CCSD School
Lauren negrady